[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Eat one of these and
you'll be sure to find yourself
in a sticky situation,
but no worries,
it's all ooey gooey fun.
A sticky bun is all
about messy eating.
Consuming one is a lip-smacking,
finger-licking experience.
No utensils required.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sticky buns are sometimes
called schnecken
due to their German origins.
Schnecken is the
German word for snails,
which the cinnamon
swirl on top resembles.
They start with
all-purpose flour.
Then blend in a premix of
sugar, salt, and baking powder.
Cream cheese and
butter come next.
These fats are just
the right consistency
for an automated dough
hook to efficiently work
them into the dry ingredients.
An employee then pours
milk into the blender.
It binds the
ingredients, turning
the mix into biscuit dough.
The dough needs to stay cool
for food safety reasons,
so they monitor the temperature.
The next worker loads the
dough into an extruder
that squeezes it into
a wide flat strip
called the dough band.
The dough band rides
a conveyor that slopes
down to a narrow channel.
As it enters, the dough
folds over from the sides,
creating two layers.
A roller squeezes
the layers thinner.
A device called the fanner now
zigzags back and forth to layer
the dough ribbon style.
The layers pile up six deep.
And because they were
originally two layers,
there are now 12 in total.
Metal rollers press the
pack down and thin it
substantially until it's
about 2/10 of an inch thick.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next up is the
sticky bun filling
called cinnamon schmear.
It starts with blocks of butter
and lots of ground cinnamon.
They add brown sugar
instead of white.
It has an intense molasses
flavor and a stickier
than white sugar.
Canola oil loosens and
homogenizes the ingredients,
transforming the mix
into the sugary cinnamon
paste known as the schmear.
This cinnamon schmear is the
consistency of cake frosting,
so it can be easily
pumped over to the dough.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A series of nozzles deposit
dollops of the cinnamon
smear onto the sticky bun dough.
The dough travels under
a long blade that spreads
the cinnamon schmear evenly.
A device called a plough
then lifts the outside edges
and folds them over.
Rollers press down the
curled edges to tighten them.
Each tightly curled edge
will now become the center
of a sticky bun roll.
Angled rollers
called roll winders
pick up the curled
edges of the dough
and fold it into two
parallel cinnamon rolls.
A guillotine blade slices
the parallel rolls into buns,
creating sets of two.
Meanwhile, the sweet
and sticky topping is
bubbling away in a big kettle.
It's made of honey,
brown sugar, and butter.
This topping actually
goes on the bottom
onto the baking tray.
They pump it into the container
and then toss in pecans
to give it some crunch.
Putting the topping on the
bottom of the baking tray
means, of course,
that these sticky buns
are to be baked upside down
once purchased by the consumer.
It's a strategic
baking technique.
Cooked upside down, the
sticky topping will saturate
the buns for added moisture.
And by not exposing the
topping to direct heat,
it won't burn as it caramelizes
into a sugary glaze.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The sticky buns.
Now head into a tunnel
chilled by liquid nitrogen
for a very fast freeze.
After about four minutes,
the buns emerge frozen solid,
with the freshness locked in.
The sticky buns then
ride another conveyor
to the wrapping station.
Here, machinery quickly
seals plastic film
around each box of buns, after
which it's sent to an oven
to heat shrink the plastic.
It all happens in seconds,
giving the frozen buns
no time to thaw.
It has taken hours of
prep work at the factory,
but these frozen sticky
buns are ready for baking.
All the cook has to do is
pop the tray in the oven,
and the buns will be
ready in 20 minutes.
No need to get your hands sticky
by making them from scratch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]